I started Teach for America now 25 years
ago and you know as you may know Teach
for America recruits top recent college
grads young professionals people we
believe are the u.s. is most promising
future leaders and asked them to commit
two years to teach in high-need urban
and rural communities the big idea is
really to generate a growing force of
leaders who not only have an immediate
impact during the two years they
initially commit but who end up working
throughout their lives from inside of
Education from outside of it at every
level of policy to affect the you know
fundamental kind of systemic changes
necessary to ultimately ensure that you
know all kids in our country fulfill
their true potential and I was thinking
about nothing but you know trying to get
bigger and better in the US when must
have been about eight or nine years ago
there was something in the water I
started hearing from social
entrepreneurs 13 people in a year's time
from India to Lebanon to Chile to the
next place who were just absolutely
determined to bring this model to their
context to you know call upon India's
most promising future leaders ask them
to commit two years to teach in their
highest need communities invest in their
development as as a long-term force for
change so that's that's how that's how
teach for all came about we're now seven
years in there are 33 and growing you
know independent social enterprises
really in every region of the world who
are working to essentially cultivate the
leadership capacity necessary to
ultimately ensure again that all kids
have the chance to fulfill their their
potential this year teach for India had
13,000 people competing for about 500
spots teach for Pakistan had more than a
thousand people competing for 40 spots
and Sena port Colombia had 2400 folks
competing for about you know 50 or 60
spots so aggressive recruitment on
college campuses
you know surrounding these programs with
an aura of status and you know and
prestige and at the same time asking
folks to commit two years because for
the most talented recent college grads
the people who have the most other
career options who are under enormous
pressure from their families and from
you know society at large to you know
use their education to get on these
career tracks that make a lot of money
etc it's just you know everyone else is
asking them to commit two years and and
you know these are folks with an
inclination to want to make a difference
they want to do this but they're under
so much pressure that they can't commit
a whole lifetime to it so asking them
for for two years at the start enables
you know these programs to pull in you
know truly some of the most highly
sought-after you know young leaders in
their countries each of these programs
has a very intensive selection process
and you know they're looking for
leadership characteristics for people
who have taken on big challenges have
persevered in the face of obstacles to
reach big goals people who can influence
and motivate others who are strong
problem solvers people who will work
with a lot of respect and humility so
very intensive not only recruitment
processes but then selection processes
and then you know each of these programs
invests a great deal in helping the
people they recruit develop you know the
knowledge the skills the mindsets to
teach successfully you know in in very
challenging teaching context and I think
what we've come to see over
time is that teaching successfully in
our highest need communities is an act
of leadership you know to be successful
you have to go into a context the kids
are generally way behind where they have
the potential to be they faced enormous
other challenges you know often our
teachers are teaching in schools
generally they are that we're really
never set up to provide the extra
supports that kids need to do well so to
be successful you know you got to do
what a great leader does you know you
have to have a vision for where your
kids have the potential to be you have
to get your kids motivated essentially
get them on a mission to actually reach
that vision you know to attain a great
education and then you have to do again
what great leaders do you know you've
got a you know maximize every second and
overcome a lot of obstacles in order to
get from point A to point B